thank you
do you guys hear that
what was that
oh
gun Santa in the suit
but how'd you get in here gun Santa we
don't have a chimney oh Stephen gun
Santa doesn't need a chimney
[Music]
now Stephen I heard you were a very good
boy this year
[Music]
wow it's the new Walther PDP I don't
have this one
[Music]
what's wrong Stephen
this is great in all guns and I just
wish that all my friends could have
perfect triggered and ergonomic
class-leading Firearms too oh but Steven
they already do
whoa
whoa
I got a Walther PPS
I heard it's the best one
Walther PDP it does exist
whoa I got a pps2 you're gonna be so
safe now I got a Walther PPKs
and bullets thanks gun Santa I've never
held a gun before
[Music]
what's your name little one Carlito
gracias bullet Walters senorgan Santa
that's no problem Carlos where are you
from what is what is Mexico okay maybe
next year son
foreign
[Music]
this is a stand your ground station
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's no sip
I was running a little late
what I had is with my iPad it's not
working because of my my greasy fingers
oh yeah not again no I had been it's not
greasy's banana what is it on a banana
bananas aren't fatty but they feel oily
what is that what makes a banana so
slimy is it just moisture I eat three at
a time do you and your potassium levels
must be optimal Insurance
nope he's the he's the potassium King ew
he's his bananas raw uh comment below
why are bananas why do they feel so
slick and oily I have no idea we have
lots to get to today and by the way
there might be some we have some major
updates of course to mug Club going on
in the new year we'll talk about them on
mug club today we'll actually probably
doing some extra shows next week I'm
thinking Monday will do you can't say
that on YouTube and it'll be exclusive
on mug Club yeah I feel like we need a
purge at the end of the year Merry
Christmas and let all of it out
regarding the freest fairest election of
all time yes uh the vaccine that is
beyond criticism because it's I mean
it's God's gift to man I meant pfizers
gag gift it's like exploding chewing gum
only your veins uh that's a joke YouTube
I love the vaccine I'm I'm quadruple
vexed that's actually not wait that's
not sad Terry that's the real thing I'm
octuple vexed yes yes correct they want
you to be quadruple backs at one point
that was a joke I've been vexed four
times but get out of town
that's the minimum okay
so we had a lot to talk about today Sam
Britton the transgender beautiful and
brave nuclear waste beautiful and
specialist uh fired because uh like
Winona Ryder kleptomaniac then we also
have something I want to talk about we
have the Twitter files we talked about
this yesterday the dump number five
took place and I know it's hard to sort
of you know kind of cut through the fog
there isn't as much here as there there
was in the last two dumps but they're
really there are two main takeaways and
all references are available at a lot of
cutter.com of course Cambridge just
changed the definition
of woman so we'll be talking about
language today in changing language
that's the key takeaway from the Twitter
files too I don't know if you know this
patriot means terrorist oh and then uh
jump gav called uh Elon Musk dangerous
which is not the first time she's called
anyone dangerous and by the way what she
really means is you the Patriots you are
dangerous and by the way if that does
happen to be a terrorist organization
who's Patriot in the name I'm not
talking to you
you thinking what else no
I'm just talking about actual Patriots
okay Patriots we will get to that and
more so let me ask you this what
punishment do you think the Twitter
Executives should face of course I would
never imply treason because we know the
penalty for that so maybe just you know
like uh
yeah like a minimum security prison
the worst one minimum yeah how are you
geraldy I'm doing well how are you I'm
good I realize I get the vertigo when it
when it starts raining the atmospheric
pressure yeah there's two of you don't
ever move to Washington but they're both
equally unattractive and uh you know the
fastest man on his feet and you can see
him on his feet this weekend in Syracuse
New York and then oh I guess also oh New
Year's Eve Toledo Ohio Mr Dave Linda how
are you sir Ahoy good how about you okay
aside from the spins oh yes I I said you
got a bit of the vertigo a little bit of
the vertigo a little bit of the runs ooh
we're at a place called vertigo what
don't don't just don't do that except
right on the outset
oh hey yeshu and I both have yes
I have IBS I just always have it wow
that's the least cool disease ever isn't
it if you had AIDS you'd buy some street
cred yeah exactly people like well he
likes to party with IBS you're like
wherever we go to dinner you have to
like gauge how close you should be to a
good toilet right yes exactly and also
people have to give you special food yes
they have to chew it up first like
you're a baby bird no what you oh that's
true I do like they want to wait or
spits in my mouth
my compliments to the chef
all right this is good thanks Mother
three people just threw up on the stream
yeah that's fine I don't care they're
probably those Patriots we were talking
about now
Let's uh before we get to everything
else a Sam Britain update uh and before
we get to the Twitter files before we
get to Jean-Pierre in the state of our
country and I don't know if you know
this it's not great
what this trans person and here's
something I actually share something in
common with this person not what you
think it is yeah this trans person is uh
um has a whole thing to tell you about
um uh not having nipples
you want to know one of the weirdest
things about Top surgery nope my nipple
is so itchy right now
I don't have nipples how do I deal with
it I stand in front of a mirror with my
shirt off and I scratch the area and
kind of turn to the side to show my
brain that there's nothing there which
is the same thing that amputees do to
deal with Phantom limb I have ghosts
nipples no you probably have a ghost dad
Heating and Pete has just gotten weird
what I'm sorry I didn't know you had to
go Sans nipples to do the top surgery no
it's a choice oh yeah but the nipples
are an add-on she's just poor that's the
most offensive part yeah that's insane
but you already have them your nipples
get itchy though because of the the
winter does that not happen to anybody
else no that's just the IBS migrating is
it considerable nipples so hard getting
them on the toilet yes exactly while the
waiter spits I was look here's the thing
I will say is I have more in common with
this person like I had the surgery right
now like the surgery here where they
actually but I can see your nipples from
here yeah I got the nipples here but I
you know this I told you it feels like
bee stinging beasting I had three
titanium rods put in my rib cage you
have nerve damage just to be clear they
did a fantastic job at Mayo I'm bigger
than most people who undergo the surgery
rather than one steel bar they had to
put in three titanium rods here that
basically pop open my rib cage and now I
have an inner corset and it does feel
like you know bee hives around my armpit
nip that's nerve damage that's not a
good I did this just because I needed to
do it to protect my lung and heart
you're doing it cosmetically and now you
have ghost nipples what you should have
is tremendous shame
Phantom nipples will haunt her forever
yes and you could have kept the nipples
I just want to go back to the house
I mean unless they were like dinner
plate nipples yeah but the Phantom
nipples are going to be played by Billy
Zane in the film
[Laughter]
shattering on the wall milk dripping on
it oh no
why would you look at that after you
paid someone money and go this was worth
it this is good yeah I like how I look
the best plastic surgeon that EBT can
buy no nipples Warehouse yes you're
gonna like the way you look not the way
you feel I mean it's going to be an oh
you're good your own personal health
you'll have ghost nipples do you think
they fill you in before this go like hey
yeah so you know the side effects might
be a depression um you know suicidal
ideation ghost nipples well on what is
it could go back what's the ghost nipple
thing ah it's really not much to worry
about your nipples will hurt for the
rest of your life but let's move on and
we want children to do this all right
yeah
your fake nipples that aren't really
there will hurt you know just don't even
worry about that part yeah just don't
worry just here comes anesthesia Nom Nom
anesthesia but I'll be a boy yeah
whatever the hell you want yes let's go
with that
sure
so this brings us to someone else who is
of course the epitome of stability uh
Sam Britton is the end silent someone
told me the end was silent I don't
believe that I don't care it's there
pronounce it so this is former Vice
I'm done with science and the Redemption
done yeah you're not allowed to have
that anymore no former vice presidents
uh former Vice President Biden's
non-binary nuclear waste Guru I guess
Sam Britain has now been fired from um
Z's made-up job after being caught
stealing luggage a second time and then
this also has also included Seventeen
hundred dollars worth of jewelry I just
can't believe someone who looks like
that would be mentally unstable but or a
criminal
it's always the ones you least suspect
yeah it's really true and it's and
here's the thing that's too bad because
this person was actually making some
revolutionary person you have to be
careful some revolutionary changes at
the nuclear waste department I mean
particularly in the realm of branding
they had some Forward Thinking ideas
they did very well for themselves uh
before the theft and we actually have
exclusive footage of Sam Britton's uh
some other incidents had done more than
just stole that's why Sam was fired I'm
really trying to not say he or she or Z
there's no way for me to get this right
this person stole more than just jewelry
and Luggage you actually brought the
store attention we have yeah exclusive
footage of the other people to find this
for you it's pretty thank you damning
stuff the theft in question here
well it's nothing like bringing back the
classic logos yeah yeah exactly it's
good power to have though so here's the
thing we obviously like to make fun yeah
but we see sambron as a worthy adversary
[Laughter]
so we want to wish Sam uh fond farewell
uh best of luck in future endeavors uh
but for Sam Britain it's time to close I
had AIDS I was the only gay person left
in the world because the government
found all the other gays and killed them
as children for me it's the first openly
genderfluid person is the most important
word they're being openly
endings and Beginnings are ending and
beginning now
an energy Department official caught on
camera allegedly stealing luggage
according to a warrant first obtained by
8 news now I'm a logical person again
and it shines through now as we first
reported yesterday a warrant is issued
for Britain for a felony charge
[Music]
and you thought that saying all cultures
aren't equal was only racist
now uh by the way it's a live show
Monday through Thursday 10 a.m Eastern
you can watch here of course if you're
on YouTube but I recommend that you all
go over and watch on Rumble nothing
would that we have something like seven
million six seven million subscribers on
YouTube and Crowder bits I would love to
see every single one of you go over to
rumble subscribe over there we make the
choice available to you but you have to
migrate I I I I get it you're used to
YouTube and ah it burns head on over to
rumble and of course mug club we have
some uh some major announcements there
on my club today we're playing a game on
today no sorry we have an extra segment
segment yeah uh let's move on from from
this and please do by the way hit the
like button that helps with the
algorithm YouTube wants to tell you that
we are dead
it's not true we're not it's not true
not dead yet our nipples are still here
yes well they're over there
where are they they're in the take a
nipple leave a nipple box oh yes people
only leave nipples they never take them
I know piles of nipples I don't know why
what are you gonna do with them so care
yeah
apparently that presents no use yeah
what am I supposed to do with this I
don't even use this like just cut it
what a creep I know yes and not because
the person is trans but because the
person willingly got rid of their
nipples nipples
okay no nipple claw
[Laughter]
but areola
I'm a child it's the end of the year
what do you want today's theme is
language look if you can control the
language you can control the populace
okay and so we'll be talking about what
happened in Twitter and how they banned
Trump which by the way flew in the face
of even the advice of other heads of
state that I think is what's most
damning there and we'll get into to
Cambridge changing the definition of
woman
but this brings us to Jean-Pierre worst
uh white house uh press correspondent
what's the term press secretary press
secretary yeah this probably would I
would I would have thought we would have
changed secretary no yeah it's still
there yeah because secretary you think
of someone you know someone you slap him
on the behind and you know yeah let's go
ask for a cosmos yeah yeah if there
could be a secretary of defense I think
we can have a press secretary okay yeah
I don't like Secretary of Defense it
doesn't instill fear title I think
that's gonna work with Putin like oh yes
no I'll get the right on that Madam I
mean Mr secretary
it's like male flight attendant sure
they exist but do you want to be one
right especially now if he's from
Toronto right kidding guys
so Monday afternoon jump yeah
fielded some questions regarding Elon
Musk and what's been happening on
Twitter and his call for fauci to be
prosecuted and this really is
um it's terrifying how flippant jump
yeah is here did you know um Elon Musk
who launched a series of attacks on Dr
Anthony fauci over the weekend calling
for his prosecution and then he shared
uh some other memes uh about him and
suggested he lied about he's lying about
the origins of the coronavirus what's
what's your response
uh first of all to specifically to the
attacks on uh Dr fauci and second uh how
is your view of Twitter
as a sort of public forum and a form for
yourself and for the president and many
other officials here how how are those
views evolving so like we've been very
clear about this uh these attacks these
personal attacks that we have been
seeing are dangerous uh on Dr fauci and
other public health professionals as
well uh are they are disgusting and they
are divorced from uh from reality and we
will continue to call that out and be
very clear about that again these are
incredibly dangerous these personal
attacks that we are seeing divorce from
reality as opposed to being married to
reality which we see of course with this
oh geez and by the way before we uh go
on with this go to CNN right now there's
a poddling on CNN who is discussing the
clean energy Holy Grail please tell me
it's nuclear
and no it's Fusion of large quantities
some of this on a pod link it is that's
a poddling midsole sucker
the dude from the television Poltergeist
[Laughter]
at the end of 30 days of a night what do
you think his vitamin D levels are right
now
yeah he might be allergic to it
so okay if you listen to uh that's what
we're going to call it that was a
wrestler Canadian I think Canadian
wrestler
said that Elon Musk is dangerous and
notice she said and these kinds of
personal no no it's not a personal
attack calling for the criminal
prosecution of somebody an investigation
is not a personal attack personal attack
is saying that you know fauci's a butter
soft little [ __ ] who can't pitch a
baseball and kills puppies yes tortures
them I don't know if he killed them well
I'm sure they died when their faces were
eaten yeah or the vocal cords cut out
but you know who's to say you don't know
they could have lived a very rich
fulfilling life after fauci tried to
kill them or an awful one it could have
been that too it just never that's most
likely I just didn't want people to tune
out because they were left with no hope
but if you are a dog in fauci's care
there is no hope no no none so she says
this is dangerous first off it's not a
personal attack it's not ad hominem and
let me tell you what's dangerous is
someone in the government determining
who is dangerous
you know you know who else determined
who was dangerous I'm not saying that
she's Stalin Hitler Guevara Batista
Castro you can go to Maduro you can go
Chavez take your pick they determine who
is the government should not determine
who is dangerous based on speech or
opinions someone is dangerous if they
commit a crime she's saying that Elon
Musk is dangerous because he is saying
with information that he now has that we
don't by the way he is saying hey we
need to investigate we need to prosecute
fauci that now makes you potentially a
domestic terrorist I guarantee you Elon
Musk would bet my life is on a watch
list at this point oh yeah absolutely by
far I have no doubt in my mind let me
ask you comment below it's a sliding
scale who determines what is dangerous
what should be
uh the litmus test to determine who is
dangerous I think that it should always
be the law if it's a crime someone
commits a crime okay that's dangerous if
they're speaking and you don't like what
they have to say sorry change the
channel or you know online just open a
new tab I don't know we used to say
change the channel it's not really
relevant anymore just you know open a
new tab well he's leaking facts yes that
seems to be the real problem yes and he
by the way he didn't say you know gather
him up with pitchforks with everybody in
the center of a town and just have a mob
rule he's saying prosecute that's a
legal process right right now what
you're doing with Donald Trump is saying
oh he's got to go to jail he's got to be
convicted of this he can never run for
president again he did this he did this
put it put him in jail but that's
totally fine it's not dangerous to say
that about a former president and the
probably one of the top people running
for the presidency again in 2024 yeah
it's not dangerous to say that about
your political opponents no really
that's interesting KJ no there's nothing
wrong with wielding power as you uh
stand up there yeah you're just I just I
can't check the names KJ kjp to
everybody it's all John fit these days
well she says it's dangerous who's
dangerous too she says to fauci why is
it dangerous to fauci because it's
actual information coming out about
things that he did stop breaking
[Laughter]
break you can't call fauci a piece of
[ __ ] why because he's clearly a piece oh
[ __ ] yes it's true please stop pointing
at the piece of [ __ ] yes pile of [ __ ]
I apologize like I said PG-13 if you I
don't know why you guys have like eight
year olds watching this show they
shouldn't be it's not our fault well I
think that it's fair that even
eight-year-olds know what he is yeah
that's true that's true we should
probably say Pooh he's a piece of poo
he's a piece of poo children remember
that now let's go through some of the
things that I would argue are dangerous
coming from yeah uh who by the way of
course gets to wield the power of the
government
um here she is discussing the recession
and of course being factually incorrect
lying to them either lying or
incompetence I'm willing to bet lying
because no one buys that we have the
strongest economy in modern American
history here's Jean-Pierre being
dangerous herself when we look at where
we are economic quickly and we are in a
strong we are stronger economically than
we have been uh in history when you look
at the unemployment numbers at 3.6
percent uh when you look at the jobs
numbers uh more than 8.7 million of new
jobs created that is important Okay so
we've done a whole segment rebutting
this uh when she said that in July
inflation was at best at 8.5 percent if
you were using the same metrics that we
would have been using during the Carter
and during the Reagan Administration it
would be well into the double digits the
worst inflation that we've seen ever in
modern American history just to give an
idea grocery prices were up well over 13
percent the highest price since 1979. so
you know that that's not true what do
you think happens when someone in a
position of authority says this is the
greatest economy that we've and and
someone else speaks out and says oh
that's a lie that's dangerous that's
dangerous you're showing mistrust in
institutions this is all predicated on
the idea that it's dangerous to sow
mistrust in your medical institutions by
the way the Medical Institution is fauci
how do I know he said that the denying
him is denying science he said that he
said people who are against me are
really against science thank you judge
science if they say the economy is great
you say actually no it's not because I'm
living it that's dangerous that's
dangerous you're sowing mistrust and
this Administration and the economic
experts the advisors so basically
anything that goes against what they
want to tell you is dangerous you're a
Maga extremist remember that's actually
something that former Vice President Joe
Biden said here's another dangerous
example
uh this is her I believe on gas prices
uh that they were going they were going
up and she of course tried to deflect
it's a lot more nuanced than that right
um Peter you know this looks like there
have been Global challenges Prince's dry
cleaner screwed up when I say all
meaning other countries
there's been pandemic and there's been
Putin's war and Putin's War has
increase gas prices at the pump yeah
okay that's bull crap but let's go to
Biden right now because she just said
it's the strongest economy let's see
what former vice president buy nothing
up my sleeves live right now saying we
need an economy that's not boom or Bus
Let's see what he has to say right now
it's 400 a month that's a genuine Savage
this matters so many families with loved
ones who have diabetes and rely on
insulin to survive going from average of
400 down to 15 or 35 dollars a month
in January they won't have to choose
between paying their insulin paying for
their insulin in many cases putting food
on the table it matters
it's real savings I don't know if you
know that's the first president in
modern history to bring down the price
of pharmaceutical drugs was Donald Trump
hold on hold on when he started talking
I think the Dow was up over 300 points
it's now only up to 26. the market talks
the lower it yes oh gosh it's still
going on let me know what else he has to
say a few years
well they're so for a lot of folks
things are still pretty rough
okay there you go that's enough she just
said it's the strongest economy for a
lot of folks things are still pretty
much so let's tell you that you're
saving for seniors are saving 400 yeah
how much more are they spending
and what about not just seniors what
about the rest of Americans so right
there in real time she just said it was
the strongest economy he just kind of
admitted saying for some people it's
really rough what he means by some
people is the vast majority of people in
comparison to the previous
administration so we just had her
talking about gasp hey I think that's
dangerous because she just said oh it's
because of it's because of uh it's
because of Putin well gas prices were
going up well before that war yeah and
by the way the United States is the
world's top crude oil producer just to
be clear and you know why that's
dangerous because if you tell people hey
gas prices are going up and the reason
we're being squeezed is because of Putin
and his War then you have more Americans
who support tens of billions of dollars
being given to a war that they don't
need to be involved with
that to me is dangerous the dishonesty
that could lead us into war
no how about when President Biden said
that gas was five dollars a gallon when
he came into office I'm like what yeah
what is he talking about yeah he wasn't
even that at the time no he got it there
though yeah that's right he gave him a
college truck he did give it at the old
College truck close at least for premium
it went way over yes and here she is by
the way uh talking about the Griner
grimy as she like to be called the
Griner prisoner swap I've talked about
this uh and I'll say this again
here were our choices our choices was a
Britney or no one at all bringing home
one American or no American at all
none at all
I choose not at all if it means
releasing The Merchant of death
AKA Lord of War none nobody none
you gave one of the most dangerous
people alive for an idiot yes
he's he's free but offended by the trade
value yes a little pissed off like
really that's all I got you gave away
one of the most dangerous criminals on
Earth
for some for a woman who won't steal
sorry he won't steal he won't kneel who
will only won't stand we'll only kneel
for that the point is she's sprouting
okay I don't know how to get through
this even if you gave a Russian that's
here in America in prison for Coke it
wouldn't be an even trade no that's true
it's a very good analogy it's
astonishing yes none
just to be clear
no person at all also think about this
what she's basically saying is Russia
gave us the ultimatum and we had no
negotiating power why well because this
guy's [ __ ]
have you seen him speak yes have you
seen him speak so just leaked down his
face and we took it as a yes it wasn't
really so much soup as it was a blended
steak yes it was the best everything he
drinks was a form of milkshake he's the
same waiter as you by the way hit the
like button hit the share button right
now sharing is caring because the
algorithm is on YouTube they all care
about the likes and whatever go watch on
Rumble okay also wonder sponsor to the
show Walther Firearms are the official
Firearms of official firearm sponsor a
lot of cutter Studios I actually went to
them just so you know because I carry
their firearms and it's a match made in
heaven you can go look up their PDP just
do this waltherarms.com you can go
online find a dealer all I ask is just
go and try it if you're looking for
Chris for Christmas for maybe a firearm
try it just try the Walther and they're
fine with me saying I don't need to say
anything else Run a search search any
whatever they're using bang that bent
back paper clip I don't give a crap
purple gorilla what was it Bonzo buddy
early on with the internet you can go
ask Jeeves Walther PDP review see what
people are saying try it that's all I
ask if you don't like it well then what
the hell's the difference let's go on I
love it so the Cambridge Dictionary and
I always want to say Cambridge analytica
it rolls off the time not the same
Cambridge Dictionary uh just changed the
definition of woman really yeah which
brings us to uh the segment this week uh
the experts are wrong
yeah so feels good let's go back just so
you see how words are changed right
dangerous that's the word that's used
now for the Patriots out there we'll get
to that in a second but now woman if we
change the definition of woman that's
how you have new YouTube policies yeah
we just could have been banned
accidentally over not gendering Sam
written properly correct think about
this
think about where we are as a country
that if we said he accidentally I'm not
saying that we say he no no but if
sometimes I say he but if we said he
be removed from YouTube
but you can upload content about your
ghost nipples
this is where we are this is what
happens when you change language
trust the science trust the experts well
the experts have said that by the way
how we've defined woman since the
beginning of modern history I know some
people say oh there's so Native American
trip there's a third gender shut up
[Laughter]
they just decided they were wrong about
that and here's the thing remember in
school you used to have to show your
work abilities that had a third gen yes
several eyes well that was a third foot
yeah well mostly flipper hands remember
when you were a kid you need to show
your work yeah you couldn't just give
the answer yeah you had to show how you
got to that answer hey Cambridge show
your work
show your work what changed how are you
wrong for all time show your work so
let's go back to then how Cambridge
defined a woman
for most and by that I mean all of human
history this is this is in the way back
machine by that I mean two days ago
an adult female human being
a wife or female sexual partner huh that
was those were the definitions of a
woman they even gave some examples let's
just say well that's out of context like
wife could be anything
let me give you some of the examples can
I hear it in a phrase sure
origin it's Greek for you're an [ __ ]
that you're asking for it all references
are available
so Cambridge uh here's some examples
she's a really nice woman
apparently Jeff has a new woman she is
Ireland's first woman equals female
president ooh that one's problematic
that's right because it's basically
saying that female is a synonym for
woman oops wow what happened to biology
and gender no not separate pretty
offended here yeah well you know what
so am I there's one who has respect for
the English language yes you know and
meaning for Words former respect I
should say formally had respect for
remaining that's then the definition
which brings us to now here's the change
okay Cambridge they added this new
definition in addition to the other ones
this is an addendum
an adult who lives and identifies as
female though they may have been said to
have a different sex at Birth
sources say yes
yeah
good I don't understand this here's some
examples can I hear it in a sentence
sure you psycho
she was the first trans woman elected to
a national office wishful thinking hold
on hmm why if if it's woman why do you
have to say trans yeah they don't even
respect their own rules no because I
thought the definition he covered that
excuse me sir about your breaking your
own law
he was at a meeting about this I've been
I've been name that movie line it's
Christmas you should get that one
comment below I think you know it right
all I know is they're taking the dick
out of dictionary the burger Meister
Meister Burger
[Laughter]
oh yeah it's a difficult responsibility
all right
I don't have an out here
Mary is a woman who was assigned male at
Birth again we've just made up another
term here so now we've changed the
definition of woman we've changed the
definition of dangerous as we just
talked about there Champion not only
changed it just broadened it to me and
anyone who disagrees with me but right
here there's also been something else in
this very example that has been changed
Mary is a woman who was assigned male at
Birth we never use the term assigned
that is Goofy dum-dum trans activist
language doctors don't assign anything
if you have someone I don't know what
the the science is of studying
Turtles I don't know are turtles asexual
I have no idea the point is they turn it
over they don't assign the genitals they
recognize it they identify it no one's
assigning anything no one's assigning
mail any more than they're assigning
brown hair
yeah you assign homework and if that was
the case I would Ace school yes
no nipples though no
they also kind of paint themselves into
a corner go back to the definition a
little bit they say no sorry
keeping a straight face talking about
this is difficult go back to the
definition they say that you actually
identify and live or live
and identify as so somebody who just
identifies as a woman but doesn't
necessarily always live as a woman
aren't you kind of now
excluding a certain group of that
population because don't people kind of
float back and forth yes
yes exactly right you don't always
you're always the luggage Thief His her
whatever the daily schedule was when
female beauty pageant drop a deuce in
the men's bathroom and steal a Samsonite
yes and then claim it was yours the
whole time yes this is my jewelry yes
just stop screwing up words this has
always been my jewelry this was this was
given to me at my uh oh Bar Mitzvah yes
what what you don't you don't attend
Santa
what are you saying my sweet six three
yes I invented everything I have AIDS
I'm the last gay person on the planet
it's AIDS brain yes
stop I mean there's something that makes
no sense hey it's
what
did they re did they change the
definition of mail probably but do you
think this is designed to accommodate
people like Sam Britton people like the
ghost nipple Guy this is what it's
designed to accommodate you are now
dangerous if you disagree with it why
why do you mistrust your institutions
Cambridge the most respected halls in
Higher Learning and those making
dictionary not anymore no they haven't
been for a while come on you get an A
whatever you feel is the answer yes
congratulations you're a graduate of
Cambridge same people who say trust your
institutions hold on John's Johns
Hopkins says that we're not going to
perform it anymore because they're not
they don't trust the science oh how did
it change show your work I will tell you
this definitively there is no work there
is no work when we're discussing the
trans issue there is no work there is no
evidence that someone can be born into
the wrong body with the wrong brain
which by the way entirely deconstructs
the idea that genders societal construct
to begin with because there should be no
male brain or female brain that's what
they used to use but now there are 72
genders are there 72 different brain
types there is no evidence that exists
you can take one small study they
conducted it again with a larger sample
size we have the references available at
light earthcredit.com the Swedish study
the changes in the brain only occur
after cross sex hormone replacement
therapy they can't show their work
because there is no work so it makes
just a lot easier to say you're
dangerous and shut up
yeah all right which brings us to the
Twitter files part five I almost said
fart five you are a child aren't you
I really did
you know it's funny I was just talking
with a friend the other day you ever
you're sometimes Dave and I do this
we're so alike and this friend said you
know it really is important to you know
obviously in life to have an attitude
that um you know obviously that would
represent that you're grateful I said
you were about to say attitude of
gratitude you didn't want to be cliche
so that's exactly right I know the exact
thought process all right gratitude in
that attitude yep but I say it everyone
Twitter dump first five
[Laughter]
I wouldn't feel good about myself
disappointed in yourself yeah I need to
let that out major announcements on Mud
Club coming up so part five of the
Twitter files uh right they dropped on
on Monday after our show we covered
Parts three and parts four and there's a
lot here I don't think there's as much
to go through as part three and parts
four we'll be talking about uh Joel Roth
tomorrow I know we said we would do that
today but it's a really long segment it
will be most of the show it'll be a
solid 40 minutes and we just didn't have
time for it today because Sam Britain is
hilarious now couldn't pass that we had
to fit it in so we now know a little bit
more about the removal of President
Trump from Twitter okay so let's go
through some of the most egregious
evidence that we have and again you can
comment below if you think that we've
missed something really important we can
always revisit this tomorrow there'll
probably be more Twitter dumps every day
this week or certainly a couple so on
January 8th this is when President Trump
uh issued only two tweets since his last
message on January 6th right to go home
in love and peace so to be clear that
was we talked about that yesterday
Trump's first tweet right it's at 6 46
a.m and this is what it says the 75 000
Great American Patriots that's key we're
talking about language today oh I always
have to do that right the 75 000 Great
American Patriots million sorry the the
quotes truncated what 75 million oh the
75 million but did he I think I wrote a
thousand did I mean to write million you
may have mentored shut up it's million
in the twist oh that's us fake news
that's us fake news I don't think so the
75 million thank you Gerald
you ruined the look you ruined the first
tip I would never say that's what people
say that's what people tell me they say
he ruined the first half
but he came back he redeemed himself
good for him he's one of the he's one of
the Patriots right you're one of the
Patriots I know I love you you're one of
the Patriots the 75 million Great
American Patriots who voted for me
America first and make America great
again we'll have a giant voice log into
the future look into the future they
will not be disrespected or treated
unfairly in any way shape or form then
we have at 7 44. the key word there is
Patriot 7 44 a.m president Trump tweeted
my vocal cords will be spent yes no
Gilbert Godfrey on the Mud Club segment
today
to all who have asked
say this since 2015. he always passes it
off as somebody else nobody asks nobody
asks
show many people ask me I say no
they say won't you I say I'm not good I
won't go
I can't look I'm tweeting this because
I'm tired of you people always asking
I'm not gonna go to the inauguration to
stop asking
all the people who asked so many people
and by the way you can clearly I think
we could all agree nothing banworthy
there
no no not even close instead of saying
he's not going somewhere he's saying
he's not going somewhere and the first
tweet again recent the 75 million Great
American Patriots who voted for me and
by the way that also the reason that
shouldn't be banned Worthy is that's the
count right in other words he didn't
inflate the count and say I know it's
more like 200 million in other words if
you take his number he's using the count
that you have given the public which
would mean right at that point in time
and certainly with that tweet he is not
arguing fraud with the election right
he's also not singling out any
particular group of that 75 million
which is important information for what
comes next right uh this is what the
Twitter staffers uh said and by the way
they came to the same conclusion spoiler
alert so uh this is an identity redacted
I believe this is is this on their slack
Channel this is on their private
Communications and stuff yeah all the
reference all references are available
at liveclutter.com you can always read
all this I recommend you do but it is
pretty boring some of it uh they said I
think we'd have a hard time saying this
is incitement it's pretty clear he's
saying the quote America and Patriots
are the ones who vote are those ones who
voted for him and not the terrorists we
call them that right from Wednesday
I don't even want to say terrorists I
said trespassers
I think yeah I mean let's honestly let's
be clear about this with January 6th as
someone who has been guilty of a lot of
trespassing
I'm still not allowed at the juice land
in Austin really yeah you don't want to
go there though dude no I don't okay
well then I can I can get my green juice
uh nowhere else because I would never
buy it anyway
oxalates so these people are trust let's
compare them to the hijackers let's
compare them to someone like the
Unabomber to McFee they have a plan
and they have weapons
people didn't have those things even the
people who are trespassers who were
disruptive who should probably be
charged with trespassing maybe vandalism
they didn't show up with weapons and an
actual plan to do anything you can go
and watch our entire episode on January
6th they did have a four foot Gallows
though yes they did you know four foot
is being generous that is generous I'm
it's it's fair Gallows couldn't hang
Willow that's it was for squirrels yes
don't steal nothing it was more of a
snare really yes so here's another a
staff member here Anita navaroli I hope
I'm getting that right I need one too
Anita Airy Anita arioli oh that lady has
none of them she has a guy she has no
very very old
how are those areolis not very good
they're not there so Anita
navaroli human also didn't see a
violation I also am not seeing clear or
coded incitement in Donald J Trump tweet
in the Donald J Trump Tweet now this is
pretty important because they often use
this term coded language that's good
that's code that's a dog whistle go back
to Andrew Breitbart you can go and watch
him when he was interviewed by um I
believe it was Martin Brashear so I
think Martin Bashir Brashear I can't
remember his last name but he was trying
to trap Andrew Breitbart and say this is
coded Lang this is coded language isn't
it Andrews what you think there's some
kind of a Rolodex he he asked him and he
said what's your relationship like with
alcohol why are you asking me that there
was no one better at understanding the
media that Andrew Breitbart not talking
about Andrew not talking about Breitbart
the trademark Andrew Breitbart the man
they were trying to imply he was an
alcoholic and he was a racist he mocked
them for the comment about coded
language when they said what's your
relationship with alcohol he said why
are you asking me that
you turn it back on them and even this
is important because right here they're
saying no clear or even coded incitement
and they really wanted to be able to
claim there was coded incitement yeah
now here's something else uh you had the
Twitter sort of in internal consensus
okay
they said doesn't seem like there's
something there well their head of legal
and now on the unemployment line yes the
giant Gad yeah decided to go for with a
ban anyway here we go here's a quote the
biggest question is whether a tweet like
the one this morning from Trump which
isn't a rule violation on its face it's
a rule violation on its back is being
used as coded incitement to further
violence so they said it's not clear
incitement it's not even coded
incitement and this person is saying
while it's it's very obvious it's not a
violation I'm going to say it is coded
again language language if you just say
well it's not racist it's coded well
it's it's not a statement of violence
it's coded these are the same people
right now who are trying to round you up
ideologically I don't mean round you up
and put you in FEMA camps but I have the
files I mean they're trying to round you
up ideologically put you on a watch list
if you disagree or you mistrust your
institutions because that's coded
extremism
that's coded militia Warfare language
woman is not a thing male is not a thing
assigned is no longer no longer means
what it meant Patriots no longer means
what it meant and Donald Trump's tweets
when taken on their face even though
they were acknowledged across the board
on Twitter as not being incitement to
violence and most people even saying no
I don't even think it's coded well
pulled rank coded so now coded that's
the new catch-all everything is coded
and he was 100 he was very clear in this
he didn't say to these groups of
American Patriots he said to the 75
million that is everyone who voted for
Donald Trump so that tells you one of
two things she doesn't believe that this
is coded language or in her mind all 75
million of the American Patriots are
terrorists yeah I'll even distill that I
don't know the vast majority by vast
majority I mean 99.9999 of people who
were there in January 6th hundreds of
thousands of people were entirely
peaceful probably because they followed
president Trump's advice to be peaceful
exactly peacefully and patriotically
make your voices heard
I'm sorry that's that's coded language
for go burn stuff down no that was BLM
I'm sorry that was when they were
burning no it means walk into a place
and then a woman gets shot and no one
does anything about it right yes I
believe that's what he that's that was a
coded man yeah it's very it's a dog
whistle yes very loud dog whistle we all
can hear he had his Little Orphan
stelter decoder that's correct and by
the way so we had hundreds of thousands
of people January six fraction of them
even went into the capital people
charged about 960. oh there you go yeah
the music overlay all references are
available at lighters.com so this is
what they're saying is the coded
language is the term Patriots now to be
fair to God we do actually have a
photograph of these dreaded American
Patriots
Mr clear yeah oh well it seems like we
should have seen it coming yeah huh yeah
see why you'd yeah so odd he wanted to
make it great again when he hadn't even
gotten there yet I know
he was a clairvoyant Patriot I mean
terrorism always was getting great
terrorists yes
make George great again so here's the
thing you have people at Twitter who
don't who
every single person including the people
who had Donald Trump removed
acknowledged that there was no
incitement to violence that there was no
clear violation that there was no
violation at all every single person
including Vijay whatever now I
know everyone the vast majority of
people agreed that it wasn't even coded
one person who wields the power to
remove the president of the United
States decided to break right and say
you know what I'm gonna say it's coded
hold on a second let me ask you this we
talk about democracy and we talk about
power
Donald Trump then president
one person
removed the president's voice but Jay
again hey but Jack what have you done
were you elected
ever
do you represent the American people
have you ever
been voted into anything
have you ever been you know what has an
American ever asked you to represent
their voice
sitting president removed from one
person one person forget and by the way
this is pretty important because there
are other heads of state who are also
[ __ ] but in this case agreed that
Donald Trump should not be removed let's
read some quotes here this is again in
the leaks uh you have Angela Merkel
right from Germany he said uh scene from
this angle the chancellor considers it
problematic that the accounts of the US
president have now been permanently
blocked and that's Germany they suck
[Laughter]
they did some stuff back in the 40s yes
well by the way there are no fans of
Donald Trump no none of these people are
yeah French president Emmanuel macron
saying I don't want to live in the
Democracy where the kids decisions are
decided by a private player a private
Social Network I wanted to be decided by
a law voted by your representative or by
regulation governance democratically
discussed and approved by Democratic
leaders and if you want to wait we may
have some flights we could put you on
standby
Mexico's president
Andres Manuel Lopez Manuel Lopez sorry I
was thinking of the guy who did Hamilton
oh I like it when my founding fathers
rep yes it's funny because they they
didn't do that I didn't do it no it
should not be historically inaccurate
yeah it did oh no I didn't know that
though the whole time I didn't know it
was appropriation no Manuel Lopez
obrador said uh I can tell you that at
the first D20 meeting we have I am going
to make a proposal on this issue yes
social media should not be used to
incite violence and all that but this
cannot be used as a pretext to suspend
freedom of expression that's weird
so you've got three leaders of countries
people who do not like Donald Trump
Germany France Mexico saying this is
wrong this is wrong and by the way they
don't even believe in freedom of speech
in these other countries they actually
still do believe in hate speech just so
you know they do not have freedom of
speech and Shrine into their
constitution as we do they they were
saying it's wrong everyone Twitter said
it was wrong and then the one person
Vijaya said well okay I agree with all
these people there's nothing clear and
the only way I break is I disagree with
everyone I say it's coded so
bye bye president I say this again if
you would take the power of Washington
DC
over that of Hollywood and Silicon
Valley you need a CAT scan you need a
CAT scan and it's why conservatives need
to stop fighting the wrong fight sure
you need to vote
but
if you're just focusing on voting guess
what it's hopeless it's lost when people
try and say oh there's culture War
[ __ ] it's far more important
Vijaya had more more power than the
president of the United States and
completely disregarded
the leaders of three other major
countries
and by the way this November uh I
believe this was uh was this the uh the
Mexican president responded to musk's
poll about reinstating Trump was this
the uh is this the Mexican president
still I think it's still the Mexican
president he said uh I already voted for
Trump to be able to use Twitter the
Statue of Liberty must not remain an
empty symbol
he just has the top button button yeah
all right it's time to do president [ __ ]
oh what look at that guy they're
supposed to think of nuclear ways looks
like Matt Damon but grosser he might be
local but he still depressed don't stay
here no don't sit over here no not the
nuclear waves we're fine with that don't
send that dude freak me out man where's
my car it's creepy
guys pull me the part where vagina
actually says what triggered her in that
that could be coded language in oh yeah
the word of Patriots Yeah that's
important it's American Patriots and
it's one of the things that she has in
there pull that tweet where she's like
specifically I'm referring to these
phrases pull that for us because I think
that's that's really important for
people to be able to see what she
actually I do agree while they're
pulling that hit the like button right
now or hit the rumble button if you're
on Rumble uh because you know the
algorithms definitely do not want you to
and by the way let me be really clear
about something cool we're talking about
this if you think Twitter's bad
you just haven't had someone who's
opened up the floodgates with YouTube oh
gosh and Google far far worse and they
have far more control Facebook oh by far
yeah they removed people for
interviewing
Donald Trump president Trump yeah keep
that in mind remember when they pulled
off DeSantis who had three doctors from
three top institutions I think it was
Harvard Oxford and Stanford doctors hand
to God these guys are doctors talking
with an elected right representative to
the public on health information and
they pulled the video and then they talk
about the state of democracy being on
the ballot hold on a second Floridians
elected DeSantis yeah not you wojitski
they didn't elect you they elected that
guy overwhelmingly by the way and why do
you hate Hispanics why do you hate
Hispanics in Florida they overwhelmingly
elected DeSantis and DeSantis decided to
actually have a discussion regarding
science which at that point was barred
at that point was not allowed and now is
accepted as part of the science yeah
when we're dealing with for that yes we
are all answering for this Florida was
right
they elected him they didn't elect you
they elected Donald Trump they didn't
elect Vijaya they elected DeSantis they
didn't elect wojitski think about that
first and they want to convince you that
they're the carriers of the flame of
democracy
they hate you it is a tech oligarchy and
wojinski by the way has done nothing
let the guy from Google sleep in her
garage now she gets to ban a governor
work that one out so let's compare
Trump's tweets to actual violent threats
by the way from heads of State on
Twitter that were never banned so they
say did we get that before we go into
this did they get the code the the coded
language of Patriots I think we might
have just got it okay let's bring that
up because then I want to go to the
comparison of people who are not removed
all right hold on tokono and he's gonna
be bringing this up here he's sick he's
recovering by the way yeah I thought it
was no that's just Britain no all right
the last person on the planet I see I
said you got it there I think this is
right here okay what does it say if you
have any context or Insight we should
consider I'm all ears
uh example use of term American Patriots
and they will not be disrespected or
treated unfairly in any way shape or
form yeah yeah that's that's it use of
the term American Patriots so the
removal think about this the removal of
pre I want to distill this for you yeah
and please hit the hit the share button
comment or hit like if you haven't had
it communicated this way sometimes you
have to bring something down to its rate
limiting factor you have to bring it to
a finer point
the removal of Donald Trump president
then president
the pre and to many people write the
people's president you know so people
would call it the people's president
like they say people's Champion I mean
people like them people don't like Joe
Biden the removal of President Trump
came down to one person which I again
vetoing everyone else including Prime
Ministers and presidents across the
world and her own employees
acknowledging that there was no clear
violation of guidelines but it all came
down the removal of President Trump from
the public sphere because then it was
followed of course on YouTube everywhere
else Facebook the removal of President
Trump came into one person which I get
and the word Patriots
that was the justification for the
removal of a sitting president
he said American Patriots and one person
said
that's coded for terrorism
do you feel free you think these people
are the carriers of the flame of
democracy that's what it comes down to
now let's compare that him discussing
American Patriots go home in peace and
love
let's compare to the actual violent
threats uh that were never removed from
Twitter so this was from June 2018
Ayatollah Khomeini uh Iran Israel is a
malignant cancerous tumor in the West
Asian region that has to be removed and
eradicated well that doesn't seem coded
oh geez he uh eradicated yeah that seems
pretty they didn't even delete the Tweet
they didn't even delete the Tweet well
it's not really a dog whistle it's just
calling for murder yes exactly did they
put a label on it at all maybe like a uh
you know hey Jews aren't bad yeah I was
gonna say is it misinformation oh
something if you have any idea how
problematic that is to use your term
people are going to read that and go
well I guess Israel is a malignant
cancerous tumor
Twitter says it's fine
unbelievable then we have an October
2020. the former Malaysian prime
minister who oversaw some of uh you know
some record numbers of church burnings
said Muslims have a right to be angry
and kill millions of French people for
the massacres of the past
what hey I know look I know what that
but at least didn't say American Patriot
well true that would have been yeah I
don't like French people either but I'm
not willing to go that far right I mean
because that would be illegal because
they gave us mimes yes a special place
in half Vermont oh here's October 2021.
uh Ethiopian Prime Minister ABI Ahmed
called for citizens to take up arms
against its uh one of its northern
states uh the the tigray region Tigre
recently literally literally calling for
violence get your guns get your knives
get your machetes and go to this region
that's exactly what they did in Rwanda
the the the radio station hotels exactly
the radio station basically was like hey
go and hunt them down here's where they
are yeah exactly what he's using Twitter
for right there he's basically saying
hey guys we should go take up arms
against these people and kill them and
Twitter thought that was okay to leave
up and probably because they had a
policy in place that said if a world
leader is speaking out somebody who's
elected it's going to have to cross an
incredibly big red line for us to be
able to remove that or even do anything
to throttle that from getting out to
other people and in this case I can't
even go back to this stuff if he had
just said
American Patriots will not be
disrespected blah blah blah it would
still not cross the line but at least
you could go well there wasn't
surrounding context in the same freaking
tweet he said the 75 million he defined
the American Patriots in the Tweet yes
so there's no ambiguity there is no dog
whistle if somebody took it as a dog
whistle they're looking too hard for it
yes exactly they're the guy in the
basement he called me to act as opposed
to someone saying we have to eradicate
the Jews yes exactly I don't think you
need to look for it it's just just right
in front of your face hey what happened
to your face and your hands they're
missing yeah but I did say to Rwanda in
Express last night
they don't have frequent stay points no
they don't leave the light off for you
[Laughter]
thing too uh because what's the primary
difference and I don't mean the primary
difference that like you just said
president Trump then president Trump of
course the sitting president did not
call for violence uh and that there was
no coded language sure of course that
but there's another difference
Malaysian prime minister right we're
talking about that Ayatollah Khomeini
we're talking about the the Ethiopian
Prime Minister these people are actually
calling for violence and genocide
it tells you that not all countries are
equal not all con not all cultures are
equal Twitter doesn't believe that
Twitter doesn't believe that
if an Ethiopian Prime Minister screams
in the force but there's no one there to
hear it
these other countries have never gotten
it right they've never gotten it right
so at the same time while they condemn a
sitting American president for America
First for referring to Americans as
Patriots because he loves this country
and believes that it's the best country
in the world and they say that's coded
language for terrorism they inherently
believe it because they decide to treat
these other actual world leaders who
call for violence as the insignificant
Stooges of the world that they are
may not like it is it arrogant sure does
the United States of America
and the rest
like the shortened intro for Gilligan's
Island and if you don't like it well you
are probably a terrorist that's not well
that's technically coded for [ __ ] hit
share like all that stuff because the
algorithm absolutely hates us we're
about to go to Mud Club exclusive thank
you so much Rumble YouTube
if we're still there are we still there
right now yes YouTube piss off well
thank you
foreign
[Music]